ich weiß den ein oder anderen nervte und
manchmal klingt auch wirklich
übertrieben aber wir leben halt in
schlimmen zeiten
am liebsten würde ich hier nicht solche
hiobsbotschaften verbreiten aber ich
kann an der wirklichkeit nichts ändern
und diese nachricht die für mich
wirklich schlimm es gibt ein riesiges
vogelsterben in europa zwischen 80 und
2010 ist die zahl der brutpaare in
landwirtschaftlichen gebieten um 300
millionen tiere gesunken das sind knapp
60 prozent also zwei drittel weniger
das ist ein enormer rückgang wie es dazu
kommen konnte und was wir dagegen tun
können jetzt entwicklung science fiction
herzen gekommen
das macht mich wirklich traurig ich habe
mich noch an meine kindheit auf dem land
mitten zwischen feldern haben wir
gewohnt
und wenn ich im frühling morgens
aufgestanden bin wird zum sonnenaufgang
dann war es wirklich ein unglaubliches
vogelgezwitscher das hörte sich wie im
urwald an
ich habe das mal aus aktuellen aufnahmen
zusammen gemischt so ungefähr hat
abgeklungen absolut irre
und so hört es sich heutzutage an das
ist nur ein abklatsch
ich hab da überhaupt nicht nur
nachgedacht und realisiert was da
passiert ist aber jetzt hat es eine so
genannte kleine anfrage im bundestag ans
tageslicht gebracht und das ist ziemlich
schlimm aber genauso mit 57 prozent
weniger tiere bei den brautpaaren europa
und bestimmte vogelarten trifft es
besonders hart es gibt 80 weniger
kiebitze die rebhühner sind vom
aussterben bedroht vier liegt der
rückgang sogar bei 84 prozent gedroht
sind weiter wachtel startdrittel taube
gartenrotschwanz braunkehlchen und so
weiter und so fort
inklusive der vorwarnliste für vom
aussterben bedrohte brot für jegliches
87 prozent der arten die betroffenen
leute echt 87 prozent das letzte mal
hatten wir eine solch schlimme krise in
den sechziger jahren damals würde das
insektenvernichtungsmittel bdt
das gros lässig flächig in der
landwirtschaft eingesetzt wurde dazu
dass die eierschalen der brutvögel immer
dünner wurden die zerbrachen einfach
wenn sich die vögel zum brüten
draufsetzen realität wurde damals
verboten und das aussterben so gestoppt
aber wir sind jetzt wieder am gleichen
punkt längst gesagt bin ich überfragt
wie das problem zu lösen es für die
vögel ist die moderne landwirtschaft
eine wüste es gibt einfach zu wenig
nahrung im biosphärenreservat
schorfheide-chorin berlin hat man das
genauer untersucht den maisfeldern jetzt
weiß ich warum ich das deutlich macht
bräuchten rebhühner zum beispiel jeden
tag 32 stunden um ausreichend nahrung zu
finden
der tag hat leider nur 24 rebhühner
würden dort also schlichtweg verhungern
es werden zu viele
insektenvernichtungsmittel eingesetzt
insekten denn für viele brutvögel eine
wichtige nahrung es wird immer mehr
winterweizen angebaut
zahlreiche vögel dann im frühling zu
hoch um nahrung und städten zu finden
experten raten jetzt weniger chemie
lebensraum für die vögel schaffen und
dafür den anteil der öko- landwirtschaft
auf 50 prozent erhöhen wie weit sind im
moment kann immer sechs prozent
ansonsten sieht es düster aus und
irgendwann haben wir den spielen
frühling eine schlimme vorstellung ob
etwas unternommen wird und wie es mit
dem vogelsterben weitergeht das erfahrt
ihr natürlich hier bei pixum um nichts
zu verpassen droht mir einfach hier ein
abo aufsaugen vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke falls er schon etwas verpasst
haben solltet hier geht es zu den besten
videos von seinen sitzen
gesamt bleibt dran